everything you've ever wanted since you
were old enough to want anything it's
all y'all said the taking are you afraid
good
you're in the great game now and the
great game is terrifying what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones Season 8 Q&A
video once again it's time for me to
answer some more of your questions this
time I made the announcement on my
Twitter page that way I could get some
different people involved and I'm glad I
did because I got some really great
questions this time most of you should
know how I do this by now I will answer
as many as I can and still try to keep
the video under 20 minutes long that way
I don't take up too much of your time
so with that being said let's get
started the first thing I want to show
you is very interesting it was actually
an email that was sent to me before I
decided to do this video so I figured
out what included during this Q&A this
person says I was watching the scene
where the night King breaks the wall
with the dragon specifically I was
looking at the fire and he got me
thinking what if Jon Snow is immune to
that blue fire he is not immune to
regular fire nor is he immune to ice but
what if he is immune to the combination
of the two
since Jon is made of Ice and Fire
himself the night Kings dragon is
essentially invincible and it would
explain what Jon Snow is special because
so far he is the one without any sort of
special skills other than his sword okay
I actually thought this was a
fascinating concept obviously there
isn't much evidence to help support this
idea but I thought it was a great
question that I never even considered
now you are right Jon is not immune to
fire people still ask me this question
all the time because some people assume
Targaryen czar immune to fire but they
are not Daenerys was able to walk
through fire because of the blood magic
that was involved she is able to
withstand high temperatures of heat at
all times
but being an actual fire is a different
story Jon Snow cannot pick up hot
objects like Daenerys can we have seen
Daenerys pick up burning hot dragon eggs
without her hand burning but back in
season one Jon burnt his hand when he
threw the lantern on the white in the
books Jon's hand is damaged for quite
some time
throughout pretty much all of the books
Jon is constantly flexing his fingers
because of the injury he sustained when
he grabbed the hot-ass lantern you said
John is not immune to ice but I would
like to think he can was
dan much colder temperatures than most
people since John does have the blood of
the old kings of the north the old kings
of winter they may be able to be exposed
to frigid temperatures for a very long
time lady Catelyn makes a comment in the
books about Ned being used to the cold
lady Catelyn said Ned would walk around
their bedroom naked in the middle of the
winter while she was freezing Ned would
be buck-ass naked and not have any cold
chills this could explain why John was
able to survive his fall into the frozen
lake you can only imagine how cold that
water must have been especially with the
night king standing nearby when we know
he brings the cold with him John
definitely froze his ass off but it
didn't kill him so since John has the
blood made up of ice and fire can he
withstand the fire coming from the ice
dragon honestly I have no idea
you would think since John is made up of
two very powerful bloodlines he would
have some special abilities other than
just sword fighting and going down on
chicks Bloodraven is the only other
character who is made up of Ice and Fire
and we see what he is capable of the
reason why I wanted to talk about this
email is because I was very interested
in seeing what some of you had to say
about this concept I guess you could say
the knight Kings dragon is technically
Ice and Fire as well just like John
dragons are fire made flesh
but now Viserion has been taken over by
the king of ice could you consider his
fire to be made up of ice and fire it is
blue like ice but it still melted the
wall blue fire is said to be several
times hotter than normal fire so I
highly doubt Jon would be able to
withstand a blast from vissarion's flame
but I really like this idea because of
the ice and fire parallels the only way
to test this theory would be to have
John get hit by the flame but comment
down below and give me your thoughts on
this I would like to discuss this
further but there isn't a whole lot of
evidence to back up the claim as of
right now I'll have to say no because
John has been burnt before the next
question comes from a Twitter user known
as de télévision Arry it says do you or
anyone know a bit more about medieval
societies did John forfeit his claim to
the throne by bending the knee to Danny
or does the revelation of his parents
reverse this decision well I'm not
well-versed in medieval societies
or politics for that matter but I
believe I have the right answers for you
the answer to both of your questions is
yes when John Ben theny - daenerys it
did forfeit his crown in the north the
only reason why John became king in the
north is because they were an open
rebellion against Cersei Lannister they
says the same reason why raw became king
in the north
because they were not acknowledging the
king or queen at the time since John
bent the knee to Daenerys he has
acknowledging the fact that she is the
queen of the Seven Kingdoms which means
John would technically be the warden of
the north like Ned Stark was but this is
assuming John wouldn't give that
responsibility to Songza since he said
she was the Lady of Winterfell anyway
but if you go back and watch songs in
Littlefinger's conversation about this
they actually answer the question in
that episode this is the way he's always
been never asked for my opinion why
don't you start man I can't believe he'd
surrender the northern crown without
consulting you this is his writing his
signature he pledged to fight for
Daenerys Targaryen bent the knee since
John did bend the knee he is no longer
the king in the north
which is one of the reasons why Sanjay
and Littlefinger had their concerns John
gave up a lot of his power by doing this
but he also gained the strength of the
entire Targaryen army plus the remaining
dragons even though Daenerys offered to
help John before he bent the knee but
since Daenerys lost one of her dragons
trying to save John he probably felt it
was only right to give something back
and I'm not just talking about his long
claw now on the other hand since John is
a legitimate Targaryen he is actually
the heir to the Seven Kingdoms
even though Daenerys is his aunt John is
the last living son of Rhaegar Targaryen
they made sure to have brains say that
John a is the heir to the Iron Throne
so John may have bent the knee but he
would still be the king when the news
about his parents is revealed
now the Narus could oppose him and
challenge him for the position just like
she's doing with Cersei but I don't
think John will want to be king any
that's why he was so quick to give up
the title in the first place John has no
desire to rule the Seven Kingdoms he
just wants to protect his family and
defeat the night king in order to save
humanity
I fully believe John will pass on his
chance of becoming king of Westeros
just like maester aemon did maester
aemon was one of John's mentors Annie
told John the story about how he could
have became king but he passed on the
opportunity and I think John will do the
same this next question comes from the
elite gamer and he says do you think
we'll see Essos again I mean I know
Melisandre is going there but we might
not actually see it she could just show
up with the fiery hand in the north you
are absolutely right Melisandre did say
she was going there and I do believe she
is however like he said that doesn't
mean we need to see it they might try
and pinch some pennies by just having
Melisandre show up in Westeros again in
order to show Essos they would have to
build an entire new set and hire several
if not hundreds of extras if they
decided to show the red temple and its
followers of role or we already know
they are short on time with only having
six episodes to wrap everything up but I
am very optimistic with this one I
actually believe we will see esos what
they should not do is another deus ex
machina by having Melisandre show up out
of the blue to save the day
like Littlefinger did at the Battle of
the bastards we don't necessarily need
to see her arrive in Essos but we should
see some of her plans unfold while she
is there now I know there's no evidence
of king vara returning but i have a good
feeling we will see her again - if not
then her scene in season 6 was pointless
she said that Danny was the princess who
was promised and she said she fully
supported her then she told Varys he has
nothing to worry about so long as he
stays loyal to Danny why have her show
up and threaten Varys the way that she
did if there wasn't going to be some
kind of payoff with this character not
to mention Melisandre guaranteed Varys
would die so his fate is obviously
intertwined with whirl or I believe
there is a very good story to tell with
those characters crossing paths again
she may try and summon any follower of
her
or by telling them the darkness that
they are always preaching about is
finally here now it's time to put your
money where your mouth is
she told John she could help him defeat
the night king so now it's time to prove
it let's see what you have up your
sleeve Melisandre I would love to see
her go and recruit some fire soldiers to
help balance out all of the ice soldiers
the night King is about to bring I might
be too optimistic about this because
they may not have enough time to show
Melisandre over in Essos but my fingers
are crossed the next question comes from
Manta and this one says could Melisandre
be Melissa the mother of blood Raven
maybe her exterior appearance is all
fabricated and not only the aging thing
okay this person is asking if Melisandre
is actually Blood Ravens mom this is
another very interesting idea because
Melisandre and bloodraven do have
several similarities to one another they
weren't able to include all these
details in this show but if you look at
some of the things from the books
Melisandre and Bloodraven do share some
interesting traits like I said earlier
in the video blood Raven is made up of
ice and fire just like Jon Snow blood
Ravens father was a Targaryen and blood
Ravens mother was Melissa Blackwood and
the black woods descended from the first
men the first similarities I noticed is
obviously their names Blood Ravens
mother was named Melissa and it's pretty
close to Melisandre both of them could
have been called Mel another easy thing
to notice is the connection with their
nicknames Melisandre is called the red
woman red is the same color as blood as
in blood Raven we also learned that
Melisandre is very old and her hair is
thin and white just like blood Ravens
but you could attribute both of those
things to old age since Melisandre is
likely to be several hundreds of years
old that would make her older than blood
Raven which would help fit the theory
that she is his mother
but they share some other traits that
family members would typically pass on
to their children which is interesting
Melisandre has eyes or actually red and
blood Ravens eyes are red to bloodraven
eventually loses one of his eyes but
it's still red nonetheless they also
both have very pale skin
scribed icecream or bone not only do
they have the same eye color and skin
color but they both have some very
unique abilities to see things that
others cannot bloodraven is known as the
last green seer and Melisandre can look
into the flames and see some events
still to come I could honestly talk
about this for an hour because I've
always liked the idea of Melisandre and
Bloodraven being related however I don't
think she is his mother I think blood
Ravens mother being a black would makes
more sense because of the Ice and Fire
aspect also
Melisandre sees bloodraven in one of her
visions she refers to him as the wooden
man you would think if she was his
mother she would have had a very
different reaction to seeing him in the
flames but that's just my opinion along
say it's impossible because there are
some interesting similarities between
these two characters the next question
is from Rodney and it says do you think
what happened in John will happen to
Daenerys when Melisandre are brought
John back to life this is a really good
question because there are a lot of
people who do think Daenerys will die
and we know characters are able to be
brought back from the dead in this world
Melisandre can resurrect Thoreau's can
resurrect and in the books
beric Dondarrion can resurrect plus you
have the night king who can raise the
dead when it comes to Danny's death the
two most popular theories are she will
die in childbirth or she will fulfill
the Nissa Nissa prophecy I've always
believed that John or Daenerys could die
in the end
to sit here and say there is no way
either of them could die would be
ridiculous John or Dany could die in
battle the Great War is on the horizon
and we know both of these characters
have no problem with entering the battle
and getting right into the heart of it
John could have died beyond the wall and
Daenerys could have died during the
field of fire if they continued to take
risks they might get caught slipping
however if Daenerys did manage to die
she couldn't be brought back to life
just like John Melisandre could be the
one to do this and if Kim Vora came back
to Westeros she could do this too since
Cain vara took special interest in
Daenerys she would probably give her own
life to bring Danny back since she
thinks Daenerys is the princess who was
promised but if we do see a character
get brought back from the dead again
I happen to think beric Dondarrion will
play a role in this they have kept this
character around for a lot longer than
he should have
Barrack has been dead in the books for
quite some time but for some reason they
have kept him around in the show somehow
he has made it until the very last
season so I tend to believe Barrack will
use his abilities from the books for the
show and the books Barry gives lady
Catelyn the kiss of life which raises
Catelyn is Lady Stoneheart they have
been hinted at this in the show yet but
it could be one of the final big reveals
I mean you have to ask yourself why is
Barrett still alive unless he has a role
to play in the end I made a video about
who I think Barrack will save but I will
also say here that there is a
possibility he could use this power for
Daenerys that's if she would happen to
fall which I'm not so sure of but
anyways I do have a lot of work to do
tonight so I will have to cut this video
short but I will save the rest of the
questions for another video because I
still have some very interesting ones
here to answer if you didn't get a
chance to ask me any please put your
questions down below in the comment
section and I will try to get to them in
another video this week thank you all so
much for stopping by to watch the video
I really appreciate that and I also want
to thank my supporters on patreon
your support is really appreciated have
a great day everyone I'll see you soon
bye
[Music]
you